[Music]
good morning Bailey
operation wonder Park is it go
they said it couldn't be done said it
couldn't be done
hey who's they it's just an expression
don't bust me on a technicality
I never want you to stop using your
imagination but without wrecking the
name broad the ever feel like wonder
Park is real of course it could be you
can create anything you imagine from
paramount animation and Nickelodeon
movies why is this here
what the park you always imagine I'm in
wonder Park
came to life the chimpanzees are tearing
apart to park we need to fight back
Oh No
seems I have backed into the middle of
something backing out on March 15th it's
time to bring Wonder Park back to life
whose witness oh I still believe in you
if you can imagine it you can ride it
the sky player the fantastic fish
carousel under coaster you guys did
block the wheels right oh that's what
this is for
[Music]
this is beginning to feel like a
terrible turn of events for us all then
wunderbar everyone look away it is March
15th
[Music]